pour commander marc coma sur place mon
gros film commencera son confinement
mais j'ai toujours été confinés depuis
1960 marié bien des vies du monde
ouvrier g reçoit des grands des
sentiments réels à moi de vous confirmer
que pour aller vers l'autre et tu fais
des csss mes meilleurs voeux dans
l'assiette je fais ma s'élève à 19
heures les verts pyjama du zou et je
mets mon pyjama de nuit voilà c'est tout
tara wenig hamadé - et aujourd'hui c'est
quinze jours - 18 la journée s'était
même vous disais souvent voir jouer
avoir chargé qui n'avait qu' liseuse ou
même joie on est le même vous qui
étaient les mêmes vous de ce matin c'est
les mêmes mots ou des sorties aux on la
joue et bien il ya un monde auquel chopé
un virus
le chrétien hockey mapouka temps bref
oui un tuyau faisceaux et qu'il soit 10
par jour pourrait confier de goût c'est
là où pressentir l'autre jour aucun
oiseau qu'on sera coincé kivu